[Music]
some disappointing news from the
Olympics you probably heard this right
snowboarder Shaun White you're the news
okay let me tell you what's going on
this is the thing called the Winter
Olympics right now and there's a guy
named Shaun White who's pretty good
snowboarder Shaun White lost to a
Russian nicknamed iPod whose signature
move is called the Yolo that's true it's
all AI next week's issue of Sports News
that's incomprehensible to my mother
[Applause]
that's all I needed to move on you gave
me the legal minimum and I appreciate it
that's good enough stamp move on get out
of here yesterday Matt Lauer jokingly
blamed Bob Costas his eye infection on
Russian President Vladimir Putin
yeah and today police are wondering
where in the world is Matt Lauer you
don't do that if that was over there I
would not make one joke about Putin no
no no cuz he'd end up like in your room
shirtless putting a pillow on your face
I find that half erotic that that's the
idea yeah I know
the Slovenian woman who won the gold
medal in Alpine Skiing is also a pop
star in her country that's pretty cool
yeah so Justin Bieber is not the only
popstar going downhill fast
[Applause]
what is this gonna be an Olympic event
miming miming a canoe I'd win every
level every metal in the spring Olympics
yeah this is my Russian one
[Music]
Valentine's Day Friday that's exciting
yeah you ladies are excited yeah this
Valentine's Day Boston Market is
offering a free dessert to couples yeah
yeah so she may be disappointed you took
her to Boston Market on Valentine's Day
but when she leaves halfway through the
meal you're gonna get two free dessert
[Applause]
[Music]
new survey has revealed it for
Valentine's Day 30% of women prefer sex
over flowers the survey was from a
sampling of women I've never encountered
[Applause]
that's right yeah yeah I like the high
five every guy here my doctor won't let
me uh everyone's okay but at a
McDonald's in Michigan a woman fired a
gun at a drive-thru worker for
forgetting bacon on her order now in the
woman's defense the worker did forget
her bacon I'm sorry that would enrage me
right right that wasn't so much a joke
just as like a thought piece yeah oh no
no I never intend I don't intend to any
of these to be joke right no this is
just a place for me to give my opinion
hi Conan's cake thank you
the FDA the FDA wants more testing of
the female version of Viagra before they
allow women to take it yeah yeah the FDA
scientist said if it takes many more
years of research with horny women then
so be it was a clipboard uh researchers
say that at least four species of
crocodiles are able to climb trees then
researchers said sleep tight
turned off the light and closed the door